[Musique]
avec vos laines frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline dans la presse
aujourd'hui l'annonce par les autorités
d'occupation russe on en parle dans le
journal à l'instant de la victoire du
oui au référendum d'annexion dans les
régions occupées de l'est de l'Ukraine
elle a une ce matin du site du
mascottime ce quotidien russe
indépendant la présidente de la
commission électorale de la région de
zapporiccia gallina Daniel chenko
annonce que
93,11% des électeurs très exactement on
dit oui à l'élection elle a réussi 93%
c'est un peu plus que dans la région de
Kerson 87%, mais moi cadoniest où le oui
l'a emporté à plus de
99% un résultat colossal selon Denis
puchilin le leader séparatiste de la
région de Donets colossale ou plutôt
digne de la Corée du Nord d'après Le
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France qui
précise qu'un texte doit maintenant être
voté devant le Parlement russe pour
enterrer ses annexes un simple une
simple formalité qui pourrait être
remplie aujourd'hui même ou demain selon
les agences russes Le Figaro de son côté
annonce que le patron du Kremlin
s'apprête à intégrer à la Russie
l'équivalent d'un territoire aussi grand
que le Portugal après de 100000
km², Le Figaro qui rappelle que Vladimir
Poutine s'est lancé dans la venture de
ces référendum sans pratiquement aucun
soutien international et que personne
aujourd'hui n'a l'intention de
reconnaître d'aussi grossier simulacre
de démocratie je cite pas même des
voisins et alliés comme le Kazakhstan et
sur les réactions à l'étranger après ces
référendum on y reviendra à 7h40 avec
gauthierry binsky c'est dans ce contexte
Hélène de guerre en Ukraine que les
gazoduc on en parlait à l'instant Nord
Stream reliant la Russie et l'Allemagne
en mer Baltique ont été touchés lundi à
part des fuites spectaculaires qui ont
été précédées d'explosion sous-marine
mais ce matin la Une du journal danois
une carte détaille le déroulement de ces
incidents qui se sont produits sur les
gazeux duc Nord Stream 1 et 2 au sud-est
de l'île danoise de borne c'est de
gazeux du 15 sont actuellement hors
service à cause précisément de la guerre
en Ukraine le journal cite la réaction
la déclaration de la première ministre
suédoise danoise pardon qui a évoqué des
actes délibérés mettent frédéricson
qu'on retrouve à la une d'un autre
quotidien danois extra bladette avec ce
titre pour le mois à l'armiste terreur
gazières terrorisme gazier en page
intérieure le quotidien danois évoque la
possibilité d'un sabotage avec cette
photo qui a été prise hier par l'armée
danoise il s'agit d'un bouillonnement de
gaz qui s'étend sur une surface d'un
diamètre d'un kilomètre environ le
journal qui rapporte par ailleurs
permettent frédéricson se trouvait
Thiers en Pologne pour l'inauguration
d'un autre gazoduc le projet Baltique
pipe un projet destiné à permettre aux
Européens de devenir plus indépendants à
l'avenir délivraisons de gaz russes pour
revenir sur les fuites dont vous parliez
à l'instant Hélène il y a beaucoup
d'hypothèses qui circulent sur les
raisons de cette accident en mer le
quotidien Berlinois d'ertag gospiggle
qui a été le premier à évoqué la
possibilité d'un sabotage et mais deux
hypothèses tout d'abord une possible
attaque commandité par la Russie pour
faire flamber à nouveau les prix du gaz
afin d'en venir mais la crise
énergétique deuxième hypothèse envisagée
par le journal un incident causé je cite
par l'Ukraine ou l'un de ses alliés des
perturbations sur les gazeux ducs North
Stream est de pouvoir faire
éventuellement les affaires de Kiev
l'hypothèse d'une attaque russe laisse
toutefois
de Guardian le quotidien britannique
estime que compte tenu des problèmes de
la Russie en Ukraine l'idée que Moscou
pour être intervenir en ciblant les
pipelines et les câbles sous-marins
occidentaux en mer Baltique ou ailleurs
reste je cite difficile à croire
quelques mots et là on en parle dans le
journal bien sûr de ce procès très
attendu qui commence aujourd'hui en
Guinée le procès de l'ancien dictateur
Moussa Dadis Camara et d'une dizaine de
co-accusés mis en cause pour le massacre
du 28 septembre 2009 il y a 13 ans tout
juste une journée au cours de laquelle
156 personnes avaient été tuées et au
moins 109 femmes violées à 13 ans après
les faits Waka s'interroge sur
l'attitude que va adopter Moussa
dédiscamara le site guinéen se demande
s'il est réellement décidé à faire
éclater la vérité et toute la vérité
pour soulager les victimes et les
parents des victimes il se demande aussi
si le colonel Doumbouya qui est le de la
jante actuellement au pouvoir va lâcher
l'ex capitaine Dadis Camara le journal
le Burkinabè l'observateur pelga se
demande lui si ce procès sera équitable
ou s'il faut craindre que les militaires
qui sont actuellement au pouvoir vont
instrumentaliser éventuellement la
justice à des fins politiques on ne se
quitte pas là-dessus Hélène mais avant
de vous dire à tout à l'heure Pauline je
vous propose la suggestion du jour pour
lutter contre la crise énergétique une
recommandation du ministre de l'économie
et des finances français Bruno Le Maire
qui a déclaré hier qu'il prévoyait de
porter des cols roulés pour faire des
économies d'énergie à Bercy ce conseil
vestimentaire évidemment a beaucoup fait
sourire les réseaux sociaux ou le
ministre s'est retrouvé sans surprise
rhabillée pour l'hiver sans surprise non
merci beaucoup Hélène c'était l'armée de